welcome to this video playing wargasm
orgasm from Sweden with Queens gambit
accepted okay yeah this Queen e2 is a
recent new idea Chet white is playing
with some success surprisingly but it
seems that white some nice development
advantage gives them gives him a little
a little edge in this position type
let's see I'm playing this for the first
time I only recently saw this idea okay
so light you five probably making it
difficult for black now to ever capture
when you're five and I'm really on a
seven so maybe he can play this this
this this b5 move the sort of radically
tried to free himself but not sure about
it well he can probably play it I mean I
also don't really see anything else I
mean besides really passive moves I like
c6 on something like that I don't see
how to refute beehive maybe I cannot
yeah this one okay the distance this is
also possible then Bishop b6 maybe I
just try to block it mechanically know
is going to f5
interesting
yeah maybe f 3g for winning space I
don't know
okay let's keep on keep pressure rising
f6 least a little bit still not easy for
him to play and move like rook e8 he
always has to reckon with night xf7 that
might be might be a problem okay so
g-form and maybe can play wish every six
now exactly now no he doesn't want to so
maybe I can go back now trying to use
this night f7 idea maybe 95 you can
maybe play 95 just to be just to be safe
yeah 97 maybe 97 as a move the right
moment okay night this 997 Bishop d3 is
not it's not leading to anything at the
end I think 97 Bishop d3 Knight b6 mmm
no it's not going anywhere
after f6 it's not like i have many
squares should've thought about it a
little bit
f 66 997 Bishop g3 might be six that
simply not working it's not not on
that's based on the idea that I'm always
seeing this diagonal so he cannot easily
play Bishop before now Jax and I thought
f5 is interesting but it is not really
he's got rookie tomb so let's cover that
ready for night see 494 was interesting
okay try to prevent night see form and
have Roxy seven possibly okay now that
that's no not again with this cutoff
bishop unless he can go g6 quickly looks
ok let's start with Roxy seven now take
it or roxy five books c5 is probably
right keeping pieces on
a4 a5 is interesting case trying for
something directly right age for or not
ok I need to play check
just putting setting mouse on my eye on
rook c7 with this seventh-ranked play
but it's not cleared off if this is
helping me
if he takes on be too you know it
doesn't okay job taking us probably not
leading to anything okay we really try
to play for win here that that's it's
really not realistic i believe i mean if
anybody widest better him but he had
this draw
yeah can't i'm worried and win this pawn
some it's not not that brilliant because
it activates them but I don't think I
didn't see any alternative check here
check 6 maybe I don't know
yeah i think the points will do the job
this is why i played h4 h5 to prepare
that it should be enough those two pawns
I should just take the draw i believe
black forfeits on time I mean around
here I had a position where I think I
had some pressure after i got an f5 it
looks like it but here here i'm doing
something wrong maybe maybe i need to
really first prevent the rook coming in
i don't know or hear the trade and
difficult stuff really redid the Jackals
so here i went here and t i woulda feel
I would have maybe taken the draw I
don't know King f3 is good it seems
somehow man i don't think i would have
played that I think I rather would have
repeated but he I'm really better with a
4 a 5 coming maybe this is this is
somehow summer holding but check five I
mean I really had the sacrificial idea
and yeah it is winning okay then that
was a really good way to finish the game
I wasn't totally sure but it seems to
win Rookie oneness also move it's quite
interesting and this is checkmate but I
have g5 I didn't see why this was really
lucky
and wide wins so I had the roof the
right hunch but I didn't clearly
calculate it completely Wow okay thanks
for watching